tu non mais moi j'ai juste on peut voir
de ce dossier c'est que m
moi je suis de m6 et le normand tamer xl
série c'est le m
t'attendais saison 10 je suis arrivé
dans ma loge j'ai eu des tul mais tu
l'habitude peut plus changer de nom mais
nous les tunisiens
ça va être vite compris
soraya coiffeuse en chef je lui dis bon
sens raya j'ai les cheveux sur le côté
montois qui m'a coupé il a passé sa
soirée est ce que tu peux faire quelque
chose que tu as président pour toi je
peux rien faires pointe en valeur et la
voilà dix pour toi c moi c'était costaud
reçoit soit en non quand tu fais quelque
chose il faut comprendre que au 35e jour
sur les 40 quand tu es là pour aller une
fois tout un effort pour tous les mois
je vais vraiment faire la preuve et je
reste robuste dans les pommes
c'est impressionnant pourtant c'est le
riz avait impressionné le premier est
dur parce qu'après deuxième chez plupart
expulsés qui mécaniquement on sert me
préparer voilà que le premier moi je
mais pourquoi revoit le docteur tous les
joueurs arrivés avant le jeu quelqu'un
vole s'agit mais la forêt elle tourne ça
va passer et ça passe et ça revient et
ça passe et quand tu te relèves
[Musique]